are you disappointed by some of Mass
Effect Andromeda squirts and issues well
then you'll be happy to hear that the
game has received its latest patch and
it makes a number of changes to some of
the more egregious parts of the space
RPG like those faces blue anyway I'm mad
and this is my favorite game spot news
update on the Citadel as I said earlier
the most noticeable change is a graphics
upgrade to improve the appearance of
eyes in human and a sorry characters
this actually makes a huge difference as
you can see for yourself in this video
from youtube or Tommy and for another
example character Addison one of the
worst offenders now looks a lot more
lifelike on top of all that you can now
skip the planet traveling animation hold
more equipment in your inventory and
expect better voiceover lip-sync you can
check out the full list of changes on
gamespot com but make sure to LIKE and
subscribe to stay up to date on all of
the Mass Effect news Mass Effect
Andromeda received a 6 out of 10 in our
review GameSpot Scott Butterworth took
issue with some of the things that are
improved on in this patch but he was
also disappointed with the dull
characters and dialogue in addition to
the vast amount of fetch quests however
he did enjoy the fun frenzied combat and
the multiple powers at your disposal you
can read the full review on gamespot com
but if you want to see the game in
action check out the archive of our Mass
Effect Andromeda live stream with kind
of funnies Greg Miller
[Music]